So we've had about a week of silence from
Donald Trump's press secretary and campaign
adviser.
Yes, she's both Kayleigh McEnany.
She appeared on she resurfaced last night.
She appeared on Sean Hannity's Fox News program.
And then again this morning, she was on Fox
and Friends.
Also on Fox News, Kayleigh McEnany has decided
either explicitly or implicitly she's going
down with the ship.
She is not going to be a rat abandoning the
sinking ship.
She's going down with the ship.
And Rudy Giuliani, by the way, has also made
this decision.
But this is not a segment about Rudy Giuliani.
Now, these Kayleigh McEnany clips I'm going
to play for you are extra interesting because
we now know who is going to be replacing Kayleigh
McEnany as Joe Biden's press secretary.
It's going to be Jen Psaki.
And Jen Psaki could not be more different
than Kayleigh McEnany.
Jen Psaki is a communications professional,
period.
Jen Psaki was White House communications director
for a couple of years during the Barack Obama
administration.
She's merely an adult who behaves like an
adult.
And the contrast between the incoming White
House press secretary, Jen Psaki, and the
current one, Kayleigh McEnany, could not be
more stark in terms of just behaving like
a normal person.
So let's get right into it.
Here is Kayleigh McEnany last night on Sean
Hannity's program, again, bringing props,
things to hold up in front of the camera.
I believe that here Kayleigh McEnany is appearing
at this interview as Trump campaign adviser.
Now, that's going to be relevant later.
She has papers.
Take a look.
Stay to watch.
This week is the state of Nevada.
We have been granted discovery and what that
means and the litigation world is this.
We are now allowed to depose witnesses and
notably Sean.
So she holds up an order, presumably that
is the proof that they've been granted discovery.
But look at how the grift continues and has
evolved.
I think back to what is essentially a month
ago, a couple of days after the election,
just under a month ago, it started with Pennsylvania's
getting overturned.
We won Pennsylvania.
We're sending Corey Lewandowski and Jenna
Ellis or whoever to Pennsylvania.
This is getting overturned.
Well, that came in, what, three weeks ago?
It was.
We won Georgia and Georgia's about to flip.
We are about to get Georgia for Donald Trump.
Then it didn't happen.
Then it was, listen, we won Michigan, stop
the count, start the count, whatever.
Michigan, we actually won and we're going
to get it.
That didn't happen.
Now, it's huge news, Sean.
We've been granted discovery in Nevada.
None of this is going anywhere, period.
It's a grift.
It's the final scam on Trump's way out.
Then Kayleigh McEnany goes even further.
She moves from holding up at least what are
ostensibly legal documents, although they
may be bogus to holding out a printout of
an article from the Blaze website who prints
out articles from the Internet to hold up
on television.
My friends take a look at this article by
Daniel Horowitz, noting that in Pennsylvania,
where last time in twenty sixteen one percent
of mail in ballots were rejected, they get
rid of signature match and point zero three
eight percent are rejected.
OK, so that's Hannity.
That's Kayleigh McEnany, senior Trump campaign
adviser, speaking as a representative of the
campaign about the crazy things the campaign
is doing and claiming.
Now we go to this morning, check out the metamorphosis.
It's like an ugly caterpillar becoming a majestic
butterfly.
No more campaign flunkey.
That was last night under the dark of night
on Hannity.
This morning, we have a Phenix rising over
the horizon.
It is Kayleigh McEnany, White House press
secretary, a real government spokesperson,
and she is asked by Steve Doocy.
Carly, listen.
That stuff you were talking about, you know,
these lawsuits, all this different stuff,
what is the strategy?
What is the strategy here?
And she says, without a shred of irony, listen,
that's really something the campaign is involved
in.
You know, I'm White House press secretary
and good for Steve Doocy.
He actually says, yeah, but you're both really
and she's not going to answer because this
morning it is not.
Kayleigh McEnany, Trump campaign advisor with
election conspiracies.
This is Kayleigh McEnany, White House Press.
Secretary, take a look in Kayleigh McEnany,
she's the White House press secretary and
it looks like she's on the North Lawn.
Kelly, good morning to you.
Great to join you.
Good to have you.
OK, so Griff was just talking about the situation
down in Georgia where they've got the twin
runoff races first week in January.
And he brought up you know, the president
is talking about how the election was rigged.
And there are a number of Republicans who
are worried that that kind of thing could
backfire on that particular runoff election
because they say, you know, if it's rigged,
if the if the 20, 20 November election was
rigged and this one is rigged, why should
I even bother voting?
Yeah, you know, I'll leave it to the campaign
to pontificate on the president's strategy
with sometimes or with the campaign.
So, you know the thinking there.
I do.
I'm joining you in my official capacity today
from the White House lawn.
But I'll say this.
The president has been unapologetic.
Oh, my goodness, I do.
I am part of the campaign sometimes.
But today I'm joining you in my official capacity
from the White House lawn.
So it would be inappropriate for me to comment
on things that I myself said just 12 hours
ago on your very network.
I can't wait until she has no official capacity
at all, and then she'll become just another
Trump is to lie lies on television with no
association to the government.
How is this a thing?
And my prediction is, if I'm wrong, I will
I will tell if the Biden people do this, I
will tell you it's wrong.
My prediction is you're not going to see Jen
Psaki, Joe Biden's incoming press secretary,
double as Biden campaign staff.
I don't think you're going to see that.
And if we do see it, I will call it out.
Then Caylee again seems to be, I guess, trying
to give credit for vaccination research into
vaccines at all to Donald Trump using this
phrase, The president will never apologize.
That's a phrase I'll talk about in a moment.
Look, I think the FDA is working around the
clock as well.
This is a partnership here.
Everyone wants to see American life saves
from Dr. Steven Hahn to this president.
But this president will never apologize for
putting the fire under these agencies to say,
yes, we want a safe vaccine.
Absolutely.
We also want a fast one because lives are
at stake.
It's also strange because no one wants Trump
to apologize for the fact that medical research
companies developed vaccines.
We do think Trump should apologize for lots
of other things which he will never apologize.
But they they love using this phrase the president,
this president will never apologize for.
It's almost become like a meme and it never
makes any sense.
It's actually a pretty good distraction tactic.
It's actually almost as good a distraction
tactic as Kaili strategically, either being
a campaign adviser or merely the White House
press secretary as convenient based on what
she does or doesn't want to talk about.
But they continually repeat this president
is never going to apologize.
And they use it almost like as a phrase of
defiance and and principled speech.
It's complete nonsense.
And in fact, it should be a red flag.
Any time you hear a Trump flunky say this
president will never apologize for X, Y or
Z, your B.S. Grift radar should be going off.
And we'll have more about this on the show
Instagram at The David Pakman Show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this.